dude the thing about Anthony Lee is he
always has the best 911 puns 911 and
cancer punch well this is off camera
though he does it off camera yeah yeah
have you ever seen him try to console
someone with like a terminal illness he
makes a lot he just puns away he has a
lot of good childhood leukemia jokes
he's like as the biggest 911 denier that
I know like he's really [ __ ] good
he's really [ __ ] good at all the 911
really make you believe it never happens
yeah yeah he's got some interesting
points he almost got me one time you
know yeah he had a dance about how 911
is not real that made me weep
he took two of the tallest guys and can
just
he can't take you there with his body
because he's not good he's that good he
caught me a little bit of that Smooth
Criminal Michael Jackson move when they
like lean like that but then in his
story The Towers come back up because it
didn't really happen but he can hang out
the bottom for a while yeah he was
hanging for a little bit which
symbolizes how many months it took the
the Freedom Power you guys got to see it